-Today is Friday, and that's
usually when I catch up
with some of my personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return my emails,
and, of course,
I send out "thank you" notes.
And I was just running --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so busy with the holidays,
I thought
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I would like to write out
my weekly "thank you" notes
right now.
Is that all right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James,
can I get some
"thank you" note writing music,
please?
♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
He's always in a good mood,
that guy.
-Yeah.
♪♪
-Thank you,
the omicron variant,
for sounding like
a paperback thriller
you'd buy at an airport
Hudson News.
[ Applause ]
Omicron variant.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, new "Magic Mike"
sequel and online shopping,
for both guaranteeing
the delivery of many packages.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, yeah.
♪♪
-Thank you, decorating
the house with Christmas lights.
It's cold, icy and slippery --
perfect time for Dad
to get up on the roof.
[ Applause ]
-Just get up there!
Come on!
-[ High-pitched ]
Don't ruin Christmas, Dad!
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, holiday shopping,
for being that special time
of year where you think,
"This friendship
may be worth $35,
but it's not worth $7 more
for shipping."
[ Applause ]
Come on.
-Come on!
-That's --
-New Year's present.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you, gift receipts,
for always keeping the price
a secret --
well, right until
they return it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Christmas tree stands,
for letting me kick off
the holidays
by putting my tree
in a medieval torture device.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-It's leaning!
[ Jimmy and Steve chuckle ]
♪♪
-Thank you, sidewalk salt,
for being margarita salt
that quit partying
and got a job.
There you go.
Those are my "thank you" notes
right there.
Thank you, everybody!